the tenured faculty
are not my problem my problem is the
administrators small private colleges
right now are spending almost twice as
much on administrators as they are on
academics all the professors the tenured
ones the not tenured ones they're
spending twice as much on the
administrators the Deans and the deputy
Deans and all these Dei weirdos the
number of Administrators at colleges and
universities has grown twice as fast
over the over the 25 years ending at
2012 as the number of students did the
reason that we don't have new data on
this right now is because it's just very
difficult to to track accounting at
these various colleges the colleges are
very opaque about the whole matter but
we do have these data for 25 years
leading up to 2012. I promise you the
Situation's gotten way worse since then
and the admin has grown twice as fast as
the kids this is madness and that's just
according to one analysis by the New
England Center for investigative
reporting